Ron please
no no way come on Ron I've been a loyal
foot soldier give me my shot let me have
lot 48.
is that a travel pillow around your neck
run I don't know how to explain this to
you when you've been down in the pit
have you been in the pit
no I haven't gotten down there yet well
I have when you fill in when I visited
the bottom of the pit on a fact-finding
mission
and when you're down there you get some
perspective about
what it all means let me tell you
something Ron
what it means is
I want this subcommittee
I've been quite open about this around
the office I don't want this parks
department to build any parks because I
don't believe in government I think that
all government
is a waste of taxpayer money
my dream is to have the park system
privatized and run entirely for profit
by corporations
like Chuck E cheese
they have an impeccable business model I
would rather work for Chuck E cheese Ron
Swanson it is my pleasure to inform you
that you are a finalist for the job of
assistant city manager well Chris I feel
I should remind you that I do not
believe that the position or the entire
government should exist that said you'd
be a fool not to pick me I will walk
deeper into the belly of the Beast if it
means I'm able to further limit Reckless
government spending I mean I have so
many ideas some are simple like take
down traffic lights and eliminate the
post office the bigger ones will be
tougher like
bring all of this crumbling to the
ground so after all that it's really not
that bad you're going to get a letter in
your file
Ron I just wanted to say thank you don't
worry about it
no I didn't I didn't do it for Leslie I
did it because I hate bureaucracy my
idea of a perfect government is one guy
who sits in a small room at a desk and
the only thing he's allowed to decide is
who to Nuke
the man is chosen based on some kind of
IQ test and maybe also a physical
tournament like a decathlon
and women
are brought to him maybe
when he desires them
although candy is our bread and butter
we also care about the health of our
customers and that's why we'll be
debuting our new healthy energy bar
nutriums
take a look
hi I'm Nick Newport Junior CEO of
Swedish and I'd like to introduce to you
our new line of energy bars nutrients
we start with 100 all-natural corn then
we add just a little bit of sweetum's
corn syrup a little drop of sunshine and
some other stuff and since they're from
sweetums you know your kids are going to
love that family looks so healthy look
at them they're all wearing vests Dakota
dinner sorry shoelace we don't make
nutrients for dogs
yet
shoelace Nutri yams where nutritious
Meats tasty by Sweden
if you can't beat them
I could not be happier about this I
think the entire government should be
privatized Chuck E cheese could run the
parks everything operated by tokens drop
in a token go on the swing set drop in
another token take a walk
drop in a token look at a duck
nutrium's energy bars are just
absolutely loaded with high fructose
corn syrup and fatty oils and any way
you slice it they're just extremely
unhealthy for you
Leslie needs to butt out the whole point
of this country is if you want to eat
garbage balloon up to 600 pounds and die
of a heart attack at 43 you can you are
free to do so
to me that's beautiful I enjoy
government functions like I enjoy
getting kicked in the nuggets with a
steel toe boot but this hotel always
serves bacon-wrapped shrimp
it's my number one favorite food wrapped
around my number three favorite food I
go to a banquet and honor those Somali
pirates if they serve bacon wrapped
shrimp excuse me
hey table 12 can I get a what what wow
thank you I mean and you look stunning
but Leslie
wow I was going for a while you got it I
was told it was Black Tie I like your
hairdo Leslie thank you Ron it's just
like my brothers he's an officer in the
Air Force
bacon wrapped shrimp oh thanks I'm okay
I wasn't offering
hey hey am I interrupting something
important impossible I work for the
government just picked up the girls
thought we'd stop by or the girls
yes they are hello girls Diane and I
have been seeing a lot of each other
recently she is a sharp confident strong
woman her children are loud
[Applause]
this is fun easy girls we'll be careful
Miss Lewis
I'm sorry
we just wanted to invite you to come
trick-or-treating tonight I think I'm a
little old can we go wrong please please
oh you can come sure we have to go buy
seven or else a good candy you'll be
gone sounds perfect
come on girls
what the hell just happened hey bro
listen I was trying to buy this
handcrafted mahogany wood model of a
B-25 Mitchell Panchito aircraft oh for
me don't sass me and I went to this
website and this ad popped up that said
Hey Ron Swanson check out this great
offer
what's your question my question is what
the hell
like how do they know who you are yeah
okay
um there are these things called cookies
where like if you go to a site and buy
something it'll remember you and then
create ads for other stuff you might
want to buy so it learns information
about me
seems like an invasion of privacy dude
if you think that's bad go to Google
Earth and type in your address
thank you
with current and projected deficits we
need to cut expenditures by 32 percent
let's make it an even 40. oh that's not
necessary slash it slash it I am an
official member of a task force
dedicated to slashing the city budget
just saying that gave me a semi
right off the bat we sell City Hall
let somebody turn it into a large gas
station or a TJ Maxx Ron that is a very
creative idea but we don't want to sell
any of our major assets because we don't
want to lose out on any future revenue
streams I hear that don't worry I have
tons more ideas
okay uh
so sorry new ringtone don't cut anything
without me
can I help you
hi my class is here on a field trip and
I'm supposed to interview someone for a
school project okay
you can wait at that table and someone
will be here sometime
but aren't you here now
no my reports due tomorrow what's it on
why government matters
really it's never too early to learn
that the government is a greedy piglet
that suckles on a taxpayer's teeth until
they have sore chapped nipples
I'm gonna need a different metaphor to
give this nine-year-old
what's your name ma'am Lauren burkus
Lauren
my name is Ron Swanson and I'm going to
tell you everything you need to know
about the miserable screwed up world of
local government
you mustard in your mustache don't sass
me Berkus let's get started this is your
lunch
now you should be able to do whatever
you want to with this right
if you want to eat all of it great if
you want to throw it away in the garbage
that's your prerogative but here I come
the government
and I get to take 40 percent of your
lunch
and that Lauren is how taxes work
that's not fair you're learning oh
capital gains tax
and that Lauren is how FDR ruined this
country Lauren
ready to head back well I guess it's
time for you to head home
I've really enjoyed talking with you you
are and this is not a joke
much smarter than most of the people who
work in this building I like talking
with you too Mr Swanson Ron
hang on hang on I have something for you
this is a claymore land mine use that to
protect your property
thanks Ron you got it
three one one well Diane for potholes
you want to speak with Public Works
I understand you've tried them four
times government is inefficient and
should be dissolved please hold while I
transfer